[Musique]
dans tous les bureaux du monde
il fait partie des meubles il a tout vu
tout vécu depuis ses débuts il ya 60 ans
le photocopieur une copie presque tout
ce que vous pouvez voir lancé sur le
marché en 1960 le xerox 9,14 deviennent
premier photocopieurs commercial il fera
la fortune et la renommée de xerox cha
stoerkersen en à l'idée dans les années
30 en tirant profit de l'électro
photographie ou la czéro graphique
[Musique]
la technique est révolutionnaire elle
tire profit de la lumière
le texte a copié et d'abord balayé
d'humières son image et réfléchi sur
l'as bari couvert de cellules
photoréceptrices chacune se charge
d'électricité statique au passage deux
zones sont cette charge électrique
permet son tour d'attirer l'antre sèche
de la déposer sur le bac et vierge à
wanda fixés grâce à la chaleur plus de
produits chimiques liquides à manipuler
avec annacone mana le photocopieur
marque un point tournant dans la façon
dont l'information circule dans les
grands bureaux c'est sûr pas terminée
[Musique]
le photocopieur fera exploser le nombre
de copies produites annuellement de 20
millions à 14 milliards en quelques
années aux états unis seulement les
secrets bitat les secrets industriels
seront plus difficiles à protéger les
éditeurs craignent le pire alors que des
artistes voient dans le photocopieur un
nouvel outil de création le xerox 9,14
allait tout changer
[Musique]
mais par contre il ya un problème de
poids
baez 300 kg
il présente aussi un autre petit souci
il a tendance à prendre feu quand ils
surchauffe même faisait rocks fourni à
l'acheteur un petit extincteur en prime
sa popularité et son succès tient
également à la simplicité de son usage
est avec cette simplicité viendra la
tentation dévorante et souvent
inavouables de copier les choses plus
inutiles et inusité par pur plaisir de
se voir à 1000 que pile